it seemed to be date night out for a few
couples after the VMAs but things may
have gotten a little awkward because
Brody Jenner and Josie Canseco showed up
to the same bash as Miley Cyrus and
Brody's ex Catelynn Carter check out
Miley and Kaitlyn headed inside NYC
night club up and down they're all
smiles hands at hand and it seems
Miley's mom
Tish even joined in on the fun and I
witnessed lzt that the pair looked happy
and playful
now get this about 20 minutes after they
went inside Brody and Josie showed up
and they were also holding hands as they
entered the venue rody also posted in
this video of Josie getting ready while
listening to Taylor Swift's tune I
forgot that you existed in the
background that's emotion although maybe
things weren't that weird because Miley
and Caitlin seemed to be on okay terms
with Brody they did send him a joint
birthday gift after all we got the
birthday card attached to the weed
bouquet and look at this et was with
Brody's Hills co-star Brandon Lee at the
VMAs where he seemed to be into the idea
of Miley joining the show in season 2
somehow I just don't see that happening
would you welcome her with open arms
yeah that'd be hilarious
that'd be amazing but else with her at
the Republic after-party Taylor Swift
was sans Joe Owen but was hanging out
with Bella and Gigi Hadid and are you
guys ready for this Gigi's new man
Tyler Cameron showed up and according to
reports they were spotted smooching and
Gigi introduced him to Taylor which I
think means things are getting serious
because you don't just introduce any old
guy to well Taylor Swift no word on how
Hannah Brown feels about this because we
know she loves her some
Taylor I don't understand how you cannot
fangirl about that but last week Hannah
told us she was focused on herself as
she joined the cast of Dancing with the
Stars I am so excited Elias to continue
sharing my life with America but in a
different way and that's through dance
it's so being very vulnerable and
sharing my story but it doesn't have to
involve a man right all right guys what
do you make of all this couples news are
you surprised Brody showed up to the
same club as Miley and Kaitlyn how
serious do you think things are with
Tyler and Gigi let me know and for all
the latest on your favorite celebs make
sure that you keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]